كنت افرك واجيب الاول على الصف تخرجت من
الطب حقيقه وكان
حلم اني ادخل كليه العلوم السياسيه
والاقتصاد بجامعه الملك سعود لكن
توجهات بروباجندا نسمعها ابصير دكتور اول
طبيب في
العائله خلتني ادخل مسار ربما ما اكون
مقتنع فيه الفصل الثاني اوريا طبعا الفصل
الثاني
من السنه الاولى اخذت بطاقه صفراء انذار
بالفصل بالطرد من الجامعه حلمك باي
باي
لكن كان الاصرار اني
اكمل سنه رابعه طب عدت السنه
مرتين حقيقه وقتها اكتشفت اني في مسار
غلط كان المسار اللي انا ماشي فيه كان
غلط لكن كان التحدي
اصعب ان خرجت من
الطب بنظر الاخرين فاشل ان كملت انت في
داخلك
فاشل قررت اخذ
التجربه اكون طبيب واكون ايضا رائد اعمال
استان سده الطب في نفس الحفل هذا بحضور
مدير الجامعه كانت شركتنا احد الرعاه
الرسميين
للحفل
وكرمت كاحد الرعاه الرسميين
للحفل نقطه التحول اللي خذتها والتحدي
الكبير كان ايضا في مواجهه
المجتمع ترجع متخرج طبيب يا
سلام وظيفتك مضمونه راتبك مضمون حرف دال
قدام اسمك
لكن هذا كانت كلها لا تعني شيء
صراحه اول ما تخرجت اتخذت قرار
جذري الان سوف ابدا احقق حلمي الان سوف
اكون رائد
اعمال زي ما ذكر اخوي
ثامر
المعرفه المعرفه المعرفه بديت اشتغل على
نفسي اخذت دورات
تدريبيه التحقت بشركات ما كنت اتقاضى
راتب كنت
انا اعمل بالمجان لسبب اني اخذ
التجربه لاني اريد ان اكون على معرفه
وايضا درايه
وخبره الحمد لله
في صارت المؤسسه او الشركه
ثانيه 2000 12 صار 3 4 5 6 س والحمد لله
اصبحت مجموعه مجموعه رموز الاهليه
للاستثمار
خذنا كان الحلم الكبير انه فعلا انقل هذه
التجربه او تجربه رياده الاعمال فعلا لمن
حولي رجعت
تبوك كلفوني الاخوان برئاسه لجنه شباب
الاعمال اشكرهم
كانت بوابه اني اتعرف على زملائي الاستاذ
ثامر ممدوح الشلال وغيره من الشباب
المبدعين
والرياديين في
المملكه
ختاما فعلا هي عباره خاضت خلتني اخوض هذه
التجربه
كامله كان سؤال
يقول لو قدر ان قصه
حياتك لو قدر ان قصه حياتك سوف تخرج في
كتاب وانت من سيؤل هذا الكتاب عندها ماذا
تريد ان تكتب في هذا
الكتاب للوهله
الاولى سوف تكون احلامك
طموحاتك هي اول مخرجات او فصول هذا الكتاب
لكن الاهم
انجازاتك هل حققت هذه الاحلام ه هل انجزت
هذه
الطموحات لا تتخلى عن حلمك لاي سبب من
الاسباب لكن كن على قناعه ان مشوارك
لتحقيق الحلم لن يكون سهل صعب لابد ان
تغير من ذاتك حتى تصل الى
حلمك سعيد مره اخرى بوجودي بينكم سعيد
بشوفه زملائي في كليه الطب اتمنى لهم
واتمنى لكم الجميع التوفيق والسداد اشكركم
على هذه الفرصه الله يوفقنا واياكم السلام
عليكم